from being a data analyst to a data
scientist what proper my group was
unlearning I began my journey by
self-studying data science and analytics
it just give me knowledge that the
Hands-On approach was missing that's
when I decided to learn formally and
came across simply learn data scientist
master program post completion I got the
opportunity to work as a data engineer
and a data scientist
hi I'm Wendy Kwan I live in canra
Australia I came from an engineering
background I noticed the increasing
demand for data professional I wanted to
upskill and transition into it initially
I learned from available resources
online but it did not give me the
Practical knowledge during my research
on course profilers I came across simply
learn data science master program my
experience with simply Lear was amazing
I was impressed by the course structure
it cover all important topics of machine
learning big data and data visualization
numerous practical assignment and
projects allow me to apply my knowledge
in real scenarios twisting my confidence
and skill simply learn carrier support
services including resume building and
interview preparation were instrumental
in helping me secure a data science role
shortly after I was previously working
as a data analyst after finishing the
program I got employed as a data
engineer and a data scientist in my free
time I like to watch soccer and tennis
and also watch my favorite TV series or
movies on Netflix my long-term career
goal is to become a data architect I'm
happy about my career and I believe that
simply Lear is the bridge between where
you are now and where you want to be I
highly recommend simply
learn